québec se prive de centaines de millions
de dollars de revenus parce que la tvq
n'est pas perçue sur des biens et des
services achetés à l'étranger la
vérificatrice générale guylaine leclerc
estime son manque à gagner à 365
millions de dollars pour l'année 2020
c'est probablement plus haut encore
aujourd'hui puisque les québécois
achètent de plus en plus de produits en
ligne de fournisseurs étrangers avec
nous ce soir guylaine leclerc la
vérificatrice générale du québec monsois
madame leclerc
vous parlez d'une forme de laxisme mais
manche et revenu québec dans la collecte
de la tvq sur l'achat en ligne de
fournisseurs étrangers expliquez-nous un
peu ce laxisme
disons que plusieurs enjeux le premier a
annoncé qu'une entente existe depuis
1992 à voir avec l'argent des services
frontaliers du canada pour les colis qui
sont envoyés soit par postes canada
courrier ou soit par peur des messagers
et à ce qu'on constate c'est que revenu
québec ne connaît pas le fonctionnement
de l' agence des services frontaliers
mais moi en mesure de s'assurer que les
taxes qui se doit d'être perçue le sang
il ya d'ailleurs des d'ailleurs prévue
dans les attaques qui a des
vérifications soient faites agence des
services frontaliers mais revenu québec
ne s'est pas ses vérifications ont été
faites et non plus à quel est le
résultat de ces vérifications et
d'ailleurs ce qu'on constate c'est que
pour le skite courrier au cours des dix
dernières années ça n'est pas foutu les
taxes qui ont été versés à revenu québec
c'était environ 5,4 millions de dollars
par année alors qu'en aussi qu'une
fluctuation importante au niveau du
courrier et des grands
et donc c'est quoi revenu québec fait
pas de suivi ne comprends pas comment ça
fonctionne à l' agence des services
frontaliers
ne s'intéresse pas à cela ce serait trop
de ressources
bien
revenu québec se doit de connaître le
fonctionnement à d il ne le connaît pas
il se devrait de s'assurer que des
vérifications sont offerts devraient
poser des questions à l' agence de
services frontaliers la seule chose
qu'il a prévu dans son plan stratégique
en relation avec les le courrier et les
messageries c'est qui va mettre en place
un groupe de travail alors pour nous
c'est insuffisant
ce qu'on dit c'est que le revenu québec
devrait s'assurer qu'à tout le moins au
niveau de l' agence des services
frontaliers mais bien comme
connaissances suffisantes qui avaient
des canaux de communication weeks assure
que les textes ou de vent qui se doivent
être récoltés pour le brut qui évite le
soir est ce que c'est quand même trop
complexe de de s'harmoniser avec
l'agencé service mais en même temps
aussi de faire confiance aux
multinationales à qui on demande aussi
maintenant de percevoir la taxe de vente
du québec sur des biens des services qui
sont vendus en ligne par des
fournisseurs étrangers
effectivement vous avez raison c'est
très complexe on parle de biens
corporels donc de bien qu organe vendus
par d'autres définitions ailleurs au
canada mais qui sont pas
résidents au québec on parle de
fournissant de biens incorporels par
exemple que les changements de file
on parle de deux fournisseurs
corporelles à l'étranger en un an du
canada donc effectivement c'est pop qui
se complète par contre revenu québec se
doit de s'assurer des d'acier dans un
premier temps les entreprises qui sont
susceptibles de faire des affaires avec
le
avec les citoyens de québec et devant
qui les a identifiés d'entrer en contact
avec eux et de s'assurer à tous moi car
les apports sont effectués pour oc
soient inscrits et deuxièmement que les
taxes de vente soit versé
tant qu'ils ne sont pas inscrits ils
n'ont pas justement à percevoir et ils
n'ont pas à percevoir de façon
rétroactive les mois ou les années
précédant à l'inscription
effectivement c'est un grave problème
parce qu'actuellement on on excepte des
reports mais il faut savoir qu'à partir
du moment où on accepté de reporter
l'inscription de compagnie eh bien on ne
peut pas récupérer les sommes qu'elle
est donc c'est des centaines de millions
10 365 millions de dollars pour l'année
2020 mais quand on va dans dans le passé
on est même en 2017 le lev est dans
notre écran tantôt 200 quelques millions
m'a donné ça fait des milliards et il ya
plusieurs commerçants un madame leclerc
d'ici qui réclament aussi
l'équité avec les entreprises étrangères
est ce que d'iniquité pour les
entreprises d'ici est-ce que vous laisse
juger importante oui petit monstre un
élément qui est important par exemple
pour ceux qui y portent pour les
sociétés étrangères qui vont avec le
régime simplifié vont faire leurs mains
des remises à tous les trois mois alors
qu'on sait que pour nos grandes
entreprises ici elle doit faire des
remises à chacun des mois alors ça peut
représenter des sommes très importantes
au niveau des liquidités pour les
entreprises et ça favorise si favorable
mais entreprises qui profitent quand
jean parfait madame leclerc merci pour
ce rapport et merci pour ces sept
entrevue ce soir très instructive merci
à la prochaine pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit